hey crazies Schrodinger's equation
governs the behavior of tiny particles
of course they're not really particles
they're actually tiny waves waves that
sometimes give the illusion that they're
particles but are they though are they
waves is Schrodinger's equation a wave
equation well maybe not
[Music]
a viewer named Orden mentioned there
were only three partial differential
equations the wave equation the heat
equation and laplace's equation at least
for classical theoretical physics anyway
now with that many qualifiers I'm not
sure that statement says anything all
that profound but their comment goes
further Orton is suggesting that
Schrodinger's equation isn't a wave
equation at all but is actually the heat
equation applied to Quantum particles
and you're taking that seriously yeah
why not okay so what makes an equation a
wave equation that sounds like a great
place to start
before we get into the abstractness of
quantum mechanics let's look at
something a little more tangible
consider a one-dimensional string like
this there's some tension in the string
all along its length it's not perfectly
rigid though it can stretch if we push
it up or down naturally this would
increase the tension ever so slightly
that little bit of extra tension is
something very special it's called a
restoring Force it's the force that will
restore the string to equilibrium once
we let go or at least it'll try the
horizontal components of the tension
always stay the same they're just the
equilibrium tension it's only this tiny
vertical component that changes that's
the restoring Force balanced only by the
force for my finger and we all know from
my prestigious Laws of Motion
particularly the second law that any
unbalanced force will cause an
acceleration ah what he said
so when we let go that restoring force
will accelerate the string toward
equilibrium but by the time it gets
there it'll be moving that string has
inertia too it's not going to stop just
because it got the equilibrium It's
Gonna Keep Going causing a restoring
Force to grow in the opposite direction
that new restoring force will slow the
string Until It ultimately stops and
comes back again the string oscillates
it won't settle at equilibrium until all
the energy is released through heat
which doesn't actually take that long
this all happens pretty fast fast
I mean here it is in real life one pluck
a little vibration and it's over anyway
we'd like to have some equation that
describes how all that works a wave
equation if you will I'm not going to go
through a whole mathematical derivation
because that's not what we do here at
the science Asylum but I've got some
good links in the doobly-doo you know if
you're interested
we're going to look at this a bit more
intuitively written in its full form the
wave equation is well a lot to look at
but this big fraction here that's just
the acceleration there's one of those at
every point along the string so you
might be wondering about this other
fraction over here well that's uh what
I'm trying to film a video here a memo
From Nerd clone oh actually derivatives
aren't fractions
apparently I'm not allowed to call
derivatives fractions
fine
this uh stuff over here that's just
concavity these sections of the string
are concave up these are concave down
concavity just tells us which way the
string is curving and by how much
so curviness determines acceleration yep
how for that we need to look a little
closer
every point along the string has an
acceleration and a measure of curviness
let's consider just a tiny piece of the
string a piece that only includes one of
those points each end has a tension
tugging on it from the rest of the
string those tensions are the same
because tension is uniform throughout
the string but the components are not
the same
in fact this piece has an unbalanced
tension upward which causes its upward
acceleration called it as Newton said
earlier unbalanced forces cause
acceleration but this unbalanced tension
depends on the curviness of the string
which means the acceleration also
depends on the curviness that's exactly
what the wave equation says this
relationship shows up all over physics
from strings to sound to light you just
have to change this quantity here that's
the deviation from equilibrium for
Strings it was a physical distance the
same is true for sound
for light it's a deviation in the value
of the electromagnetic field not a
distance but what about quantum
mechanics
well that stuff is described by
Schrodinger's equation and the solutions
we extract from it are this often called
the wave function these curly D's tell
us there are changes in that wave
function changes both across space and
over time unfortunately if we compare
this with the wave equation there's a
bit of a problem these twos tell us the
spatial changes are second order changes
in other words they're changes of
changes the wave equation has one of
those over time as well but
Schrodinger's equation only involves a
first order change in time
that is not a wave equation then why are
the solutions called wave functions well
because language is complicated language
is a very fluid thing it's constantly
changing some words are so old that they
go out of fashion others are brand new
science tends to have the opposite
problem we only come up with new words
when new science happens and then we
keep those words forever
even if we eventually find out those
words are terribly misleading or
confusing sometimes it isn't even
scientists that come up with them a lot
of the time it's journalists but that's
a rant for another day anyway the word
wave has a lot of different definitions
depending on context one of the earliest
is the verb meaning moving your hand
back and forth its earliest use as a
noun was in reference to a moving Billow
of water
these days the word wave is used to
describe anything that undulates or
moves in a repeating pattern basically
anything that fits a pattern like one of
these that's pretty much anything
involving a sine or cosine are those
solutions to the wave equation sure but
there are also solutions to a bunch of
other equations you mean like that A
harmonic oscillator Nick Arvin Ash for
those of you who may not have heard of
it a classical harmonic oscillator
describes the motion of a spring now
this may seem trivial but it turns out
that the math of the motion of a simple
spring if quantize can describe nearly
everything we can see in the universe
because its math is almost identical to
the math of the prevailing theory of
reality Quantum field Theory how is a
simple spring related to everything
check out my video on the Arvin Ash
Channel after you reviewed next video of
course
huh cool
you got arvin's video when you're done
here where was I
oh right Sines and cosines they're
common solutions to all sorts of
differential equations including
Schrodinger's equation and we certainly
call these shapes waves but that's not
enough to make Schrodinger's equation a
wave equation wave equations have second
order changes in both space and time
Schrodinger's equation has second order
changes in space but only first order
changes in time so what is it then it's
a heat equation
I've done a video about this before but
here's the quickie version the heat
equation relates changes in temperature
over time at a particular location two
differences in temperature between
nearby locations the bigger the
difference the faster the change and
vice versa it tells us how we'd expect
heat to flow inside of a solid body
[Music]
unbelievable
but just like the wave equation it's not
limited to its original purpose this
quantity doesn't have to be temperature
it could really be anything that flows
and did you notice this it's a first
order change in time just like
Schrodinger's equation
What flows in quantum mechanics
probability
I mean technically probability density
but that's not a Nuance that's important
here anyway here's the 3s orbital in a
hydrogen atom the electron has a
probability of being at any location on
this map but it's more likely to be in a
brighter spot than a darker spot and
that probability must be conserved just
like the mass in a fluid flow or the
energy in a heat transfer any change in
probability at one location results in
changes at other locations probability
flows through space and ultimately the
electron finds itself in another quantum
State this is the kind of process that
the heat equation describes but we still
have one minor discrepancy Schrodinger's
equation has an extra term that the
standard heat equation doesn't the key
word there being standard the heat
equations can have extra terms for
example if there's a moving fluid we
account for that with a convection term
but you'll notice the extra term in
Schrodinger's equation doesn't involve
changes at all it represents an
independent external influence like the
nucleus of an atom the electron in a
hydrogen atom is near a proton that's
what makes it hydrogen so this extra
term accounts for that interaction it's
an interaction term we add them to the
heat equation all the time it's not that
unusual in fluid dynamics they represent
some kind of source or sync in
schroederer's equation it's a source of
energy otherwise unaccounted for because
Schrodinger's equation is derived from
conservation of energy conservation of
energy shall not be violated it's just
the heat equation with an extra term so
yeah Orden that's exactly what it is and
that kind of makes sense when you think
about it there's nothing actually waving
in this electron orbital I mean sure you
could graph out the pattern and the
shape is wavy but there's no actual
waving taking place it's a static graph
the wave equation isn't about wave
shapes it's about wave motion remember
it was originally derived to explain
motion like this waves on a string the
wave equation relates concavity to
acceleration curviness to oscillation
that's not what's happening in quantum
mechanics Schrodinger's equation doesn't
relate curviness to oscillation it
relates curviness to flow specifically
the flow of probability probability
flows from one place to another as time
passes that is what Schrodinger's
equation describes to be fair though and
I've said this in previous videos
Schrodinger's equation is not a complete
description of quantum phenomena you
know all these Solutions we have for the
hydrogen atom well we had to make
several big assumptions to get there
essentially we've ignored what we call
the fine structure of the atom in case
you didn't know I have a book it's
available as an ebook and in paperback
the ebook is also available as a digital
download on patreon if if you pledge
more than five dollars per month
Shameless self-promotion check links in
the doobly-doo anyway they're actually
better options than Schrodinger's
equation the poly Schrodinger equation
allows for Quantum Spin and magnetic
fields
the particles are relativistic we've got
the ever popular Dirac equation if you
still really want it to be a wave
equation though there's decline Gordon
equation it's got second order changes
in both space and time but the main
takeaway here is not to get too caught
up on the language it's just going to
leave you stressed it's not worth it the
relationships are what's important not
the names that being said don't forget
to check out arvin's video on harmonic
oscillators he makes really good stuff
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
shroheim 333 pointed out that my
earth-centered solar system breaks some
physical laws well not exactly it's just
that the rules you're familiar with are
written from an inertial perspective in
my earth-centered system was not
inertial anyway thanks for watching